- [Instructor] We've already discussed
the notion of unemployment
at length in other videos.
And what we're going to do in this video
is dig a little bit deeper
and think about what makes
up the unemployment rate?
And just as a review,
the unemployment rate,
it's the percentage of
people in the labor force
who are actively looking for a job.
And on this chart that you
see here, or this graph,
from the St. Louis Federal Reserve,
this brown color is the unemployment rate.
And you can see how it jumps around,
along with the economic cycles.
These gray areas, right over here,
these show recessions,
and then the white areas are expansion.
You can see how the unemployment rate
jumps during most of these recessions,
or really all of these recessions here.
But then we have other things graphed.
We have this thing in blue,
known as the natural rate of unemployment.
What is that?
Well, it is what the word describes.
You could view this blue line,
and it's really an approximation,
of what would the unemployment rate be
if you did not have these economic cycles.
These periods of expansion
and then recession.
In some ways, you can view it as
the smoothed out unemployment rate.
And so if this in brown,
is the unemployment rate,
and then in blue, right over here,
you have your natural
rate of unemployment.
People will sometimes use NRU for that.
The difference between the two,
that's the unemployment
caused by the business cycle.
So this is, so let's say
if we go right over here,
where we had a high unemployment rate,
this difference right over here,
so you could view this as
the unemployment rate minus
the natural rate of unemployment,
minus the natural rate of unemployment,
that's the unemployment that's
caused by the business cycle.
and so that's why it is called cyclical.
Cyclical unemployment.
And so you could see at,
during recessions or shortly
after recession ends,
when the unemployment rate,
when the regular unemployment
rate is very high,
your cyclical unemployment,
the unemployment caused
due to the business cycle,
is going to be positive.
But when the economy is really humming,
there, you can even have
negative cyclical unemployment.
Right over here.
Where the true unemployment rate
is lower than the natural
rate of unemployment,
maybe people who are hiring,
maybe business just have to hire people
that aren't fully qualified
for the jobs, or whatever else,
just because things are so
hot at that moment in time.
But then we can break
down things even further.
We can break down this notion of
natural rate of unemployment
into two components.
You can break it down into structural,
I will do that in this blue color,
so structural.
Structural unemployment and
frictional unemployment.
Not fictional, frictional. (laughs)
Frictional unemployment.
And we don't have the
exact data that here,
but let's, I'll just draw
something just to imagine.
Let's just imagine,
this isn't the exact,
this isn't the exact information.
But let's imagine that the
frictional unemployment rate
would be this much right over here.
And then the structural would be the rest
to make it add up to the
natural rate of unemployment.
And so one thing that
you might immediately say
is okay, the natural rate is made up of
structural plus frictional unemployment
or if you add frictional plus structural,
you get your natural rate.
But what are these things?
Well, structural unemployment,
this is a situation
where people are being counted
in the unemployment rate,
but there's something about,
a disconnect between their skills
and what employers are looking for,
that is making it difficult
for them to find a job.
You could imagine
when the car was replacing
the horse and buggy,
if you are a horse and buggy driver,
or you were good caring for horses,
but now people were
looking for auto mechanics,
or people who knew about cars,
or people who could help
build roads for cars.
Well then that would be a situation
with structural unemployment.
Where the skills did not match the jobs.
And so over time, and there's,
you might say, well over time
those people would learn
to do things for cars.
But there's always change in the economy.
If you think about it right now,
technology is constantly evolving.
There's constantly new
needs in the economy,
and so there will always
be some lack of fit
between the skills that
people have right now
and the skills that employers need.
It might also relate to where people are.
Where the people might not be
in the place where the
jobs are, or vice versa.
Now, frictional unemployment.
Well, that comes out of the ideas
that there are some frictions
when you look for a job.
You've got to submit your resume,
you have to interview around,
everyone doesn't go directly
from one job to the next.
It's a good situation to be in,
but many times you might
have graduated from college,
you are looking for a job.
Employers are looking to fill a position.
And so this is just a
natural state of affairs.
Over time, if technology gets better,
if there's better ways to match jobs,
the frictional unemployment
could decrease.
But it's unlikely it will ever go to zero.
That there will always be some
people in the labor market
who are actively looking for a job,
who have the skills that
the labor market needs,
so they wouldn't be counted in
the structural unemployment,
but they haven't found that job yet.
So I will leave you there.
And hopefully this gives
you an appreciation
that you often see the unemployment rate,
but you can think about
it as being made up of
the natural rate of unemployment
and the cyclical unemployment.
And then the natural rate
of unemployment itself,
can be broken down further
into structural and
frictional unemployment.